we are here to document the lives of
people living in Alaska the harsh
reality is the environment we're up
against it makes it tough to do our job
working on life below zero can be very
dangerous guns here cameras here never
know what to expect you see that gonna
be tough but we're gonna get the shot
every scenario we got to prepare for
this but we're still smiling or having
fun still making like below zero yeah
bring it on
this is what keeps me up at night we
arrived to the hailstones kewal at camp
just before dark last night
unfortunately the storm that we were
expecting to be a little bit worse than
what we thought
winds gusting to up to 65 miles an hour
which is a hurricane level wind storm
and it keeps getting worse we actually
had to abandon our camp and come and
take refuge on the teepee with the
hailstones survived the night the crazy
winds and woke up and we came outside
and the temperatures dropped about 40
degrees to wind it shift to the west
which is really unusual and it pushed up
the high tide underneath the ice totally
flooded this Delta where our snow
machines were parked yeah this is deep
couple feet of slush we don't get them
out really quickly they're gonna become
encased in new ice which is just going
to be a disaster for us so we're going
to get some help from chip and tow these
machines out as quickly as we can
[Music]
this is half the fun we're gonna try to
pluck these guys out yeah it looks like
it's good to me
the fun winter task tying knots
underwater and 10 below okay let's do it
[Music]
yep pretty good system here takes a lot
of manpower we got a deep one here last
one sitting pretty low let's do it boy
[Music]
good job guys
that was a close call
nothing's gonna stop us we're undaunted
yeah we'll get through it
storms floods whatever bring it on it's
not going to stop television in five
years on life below zero this has been
one of the craziest 24 hours for me for
sure now we need to go back to our camp
and assess damage and who knows what
we're going to find there we need to
rebuild our shelters and assess our gear
situation and make sure that everybody
can stay warm and safe it's a matter of
life and death an articulator having
good shelter there's no one we can call
out here there's nowhere we can go we're
out on the coastal plain of the Arctic
Ocean we need to be totally self-reliant
this is a bout as extreme as it gets we
made it back to camp it's become part of
the ocean
clearly caved in trying to build a small
snow wall to block out some of the wind
that's going under the tents just trying
anything at this point to make these a
little bit better there's a tremendous
amount of water underneath the floor of
the tent is like a water bed right now
it's kind of surreal to be in ten below
zero in the middle of winter and Arctic
and have water issues
you know we prepare for snow and ice and
wind but you don't expect your tent to
flood in the middle of winter it's
really kind of surreal lesson learned I
guess it takes such an effort to get out
here that once we do make it out here we
really want to make it work as the
logistics are just so daunting and this
place is incredible it's it's really
brutal beautiful and wild and makes for
really wonderful television it's gonna
take some more work on the part of the
crew but I think we can do it and keep
it functioning get back to filming till
the next door
[Music]
celebrating Ben's birthday today
probably not the way that he expected
but we're we're having fun and making
the most of it hey let's eat while it's
hot
though I feel very grateful and
fortunate right now
I'm getting a very memorable and unique
birthday experience my birthday caribou
you know it's an Arctic gourmet it's
awesome it's a great birthday dinner for
the whole crew
[Music]